this trio has become Zimbabwe's comedy
sensation with their political satire
show Zambezi news the comedians make a
witty parody of state propaganda and
burning issues in Zimbabwe the team is
constantly working on new material right
now this particular sketch basically is
about race relations you know it's it's
it's a big thing in Africa but a lot in
Zimbabwe as well you know the
interaction between black and white
people so this is basically a white man
or white reporter from some busy use
your own weathers who's proving that
blacks and whites get a live being your
politically correct correspondent Jerome
rainbow is my color
weathers Zambezi news is distributed on
social media and DVDs it has over 6
million viewers while it's not broadcast
on Zimbabwe state media it has fans in
other African countries because it sheds
critical light on political realities
that's why state authorities perceive
the show as an affront I think you know
I think that's that's always the you
know the joke in Zimbabwe that you've
got freedom of expression but you don't
have freedom after expression and and
you know that's you know it's definitely
the case with you know with some busy
news is that it's it's in a very kind of
outspoken political satire and of course
we deal with we deal with with the
powers that be based in the capital
Harare some bassy news reports from a
country in the grip of a repressive
regime after almost 30 years the three
comedians use satire to prompt people to
think about sensitive issues and
disregards threats and intimidation the
guiding principle of Zambezi news is you
can laugh away your fear but you can't
look away from it this great festival
that is benefiting the it is good for 20
and
ROK's of artistic immigrants swarming
from the imperialist nations of
currencies is how addition make sure
that you have all the necessary
clearance in documents oh there you shot
you down
we always laugh at that situation - no
we just try to get people to laugh more
so that you don't cry so much and you
don't complain so much it's happening
yes life is tough right now but don't
let it bury you these are why we looking
at life from a different angle from a
funny sort of end the zambezi news team
is going into its fourth season the cast
is still confronted by state security
agents who claim the comedian's are
pursuing an anti-government agenda
considering Zimbabwe's outlook there
seems to be a need for the kind of
comedy that sunbaes e-news provides